bien d'autres après six mois de travaux
le groupe d'action contre le racisme
mis sur pied par le gouvernement annonce
une série de 25 mesures une des
priorités mettre fin aux interpellations
policières aléatoire partout au québec
ce qu'on demande c'est maintenant que la
cause de l'interpellation soit
clairement identifiée à l'individu est
que ce soit mentionnée sur au moment
même de l'interpellation
les sept ministres propose aussi au
gouvernement de mettre en place des
formations continues
destiné aux policiers et aux employés de
la fonction publique
le groupe recommande également la
nomination d'un ministre responsable de
la lutte contre le racisme
la priorité de ce ministre là évidemment
comme ministre responsable de la lutte
contre le racisme
ça va être de s'assurer non seulement
que les actions sont mises en place mais
qu'elles sont suivies qu'elles sont
mesurés et qu'elle donne des résultats
une proposition bien accueillie par le
directeur d'un centre d'action sur les
relations raciales
bien qu'ils réclament toujours la
reconnaissance du racisme systémique
dans plusieurs provinces ce genre de
poste existe au sein du canal des
conseils des ministres pour assurer
entre autres suivi et l'imputabilité
donc je crois que si tel est le cas
bravo monsieur legault par rapport à
d'autres problèmes je crois qu'il faut
trouver moyen entre autres reconnaître
le racisme systémique parce que sinon on
a toujours travaillé à la pièce un avis
que ne partage pas cette autre expert on
va faire des formations au personnel de
la fonction publique aux policiers je
pense que c'est une réponse au racisme
systémique alors qu'on l'appelle par son
nom ou pas ça n'a pas d'importance à
l'école les ministres souhaitent que les
thèmes du racisme et de la
discrimination soit incorporé tout au
long du parcours scolaire notamment à
travers le cours d'éthique et de culture
religieuse qui est actuellement en revue
certaines mesures viseront
spécifiquement les communautés
autochtones
nous avons pensé aussi aux pieds le
personnel la fonction publique en
donnant une formation du gâteau en sur
les réalités autochtones puissent
sensibiliser les autres professionnels à
faire de même le groupe d'action
souhaite lancer une campagne nationale
de sensibilisation contre la racisme et
améliorer la représentation des
minorités visibles au sein de la
fonction publique ici mélissa françois
radio canada montréal